you can't save yourselves but you can  save your legacy  you can't be here  you know that i can't be the first one  who wanted to see  my youngest self  strange watching yourself being born  our genetic dynasty has reigned for  almost four centuries  the might of the imperium  has brought peace to thousands of worlds  but the beliefs of one man  [Music]  now threaten the empire's very existence  i'm not a revolutionary  are correct the empire is dying  order will vanish wars will be endless  only can shorten the darkness  the man has a master following people  who  hinge their hopes on every words held in  others  words have a way of fanning into  wildfires  you can't save yourselves  but you can save your legacy  [Music]  you